avec un peu d'imagination on pourrait se
prendre pour robinson crusoé redevenus
sauvages porquerolles sort de l'été avec
douceur et derniers estivants jouent aux
naufragés volontaires dans une sorte de
paradis où le temps s'est arrêté
pris service fréquentation c'est donc
l'heure des bilans et une fois n'est pas
coutume les commerçants seraient presque
satisfait c'est une saison qui a débuté
timidement sur le mois de juillet et qui
s'est confirmée sur le mois d'août avec
une
participation de des touristes sur l'île
de porquerolles mais dans la forme on
peut dire que c'est une saison qui s'est
relativement bien passée un signe ne
trompe pas à bord de l'amour des îles le
bateau qui relie porquerolles au
continent les arrivants se comptent
encore par centaines autour du 15 août
près de 4000 personnes débarquées ainsi
chaque jour sur l'île un cinquième de
plus que l'an dernier bien placé pour
observer le phénomène
l'office de tourisme
est là bas
ici déferlent à tout moment la corde
coloré de ceux qui ont quelque chose à
demander du polonais peut-être des
russes des allemands et beaucoup
d'italiens
alléchés par des taux de change plus
avantageux les étrangers sont de retour
invasion pacifique acp grand tour de
vélo le seul moyen de transport autorisé
ici la durée moyenne du séjour une
semaine permet de découvrir les plus
beaux panoramas et inciterait certains a
refusé la rentrée